in südkorea ist am sonntag eine erste
delegation aus dem norden eingetroffen
die die teilnahme an den olympischen
winterspielen vorbereiten soll
die gruppe organisiert die konzerte
eines nordkoreanischen orchesters das
während der spiele auftritt die
delegation war bereits am vortag
erwartet worden hatte die reise jedoch
kurzfristig abgesagt ohne gründe zu
nennen
neben den 140 musikern werden nach
angaben des internationalen olympischen
komitees ioc
22 athleten aus dem norden erwartet die
sportler würden in drei sportarten und
fünf disziplinen antreten teilte der
verband am samstag mit nord- und
südkorea hätten zugestimmt unter einer
gemeinsamen flagge an der
eröffnungszeremonie teilzunehmen
auch werde ein gemeinsames koreanisches
frauen eishockey team antreten nordkorea
schickt zudem 24 funktionäre und 21
medienvertreter in den süden die spiele
finden vom 9
bis zum 25 februar im südkoreanischen
pyeongchang statt